hello human
we come in peace
please don't be afraid
we just want to know you a little better
this won't hurt
i promise
welcome to
the crypt
terror
the terror of the crypt
the cryptic terror 3rd of may 1336
three weeks ago a curse was bestowed
upon the town of
[Music]
livestock killed crops desiccated
madness grew
shrieks and chant were beard heard from
the town's foregone catacomb
many believe that to be the source
of the town's curse
lord raleigh commanded the town's clergy
to go down and rid them of this evil
one by one
they entered the depths of darkness yet
none returned
the corruption only grew
and now by the lord's order
it is your turn to venture down
oh
oh
you were the uh farewell
later nerds imma go down the depths you
have fun being on the surface may you
rid us of this evil why don't we go down
as a group
that's an option we could all go down
together strengthen numbers why do you
have us go down one by one didn't make a
lie uh hey wait a minute before i go
down here just uh
you know you're gonna come back for me
if i don't come back you're gonna send
more than one person down after me right
okay
ah
oh
okay
well this is um
lesson ideal uh
[Music]
so what do i
want what is this evil look like
did you give me a picture of um what i'm
looking for is it oh
no
guys
okay
i'll just be on my way then
and oh no
is it a maze
oh it's probably some kind of a maze oh
no i failed on the first turn of the
maze
okay
[Music]
well
i'm not sure what kind of catacombs
these are supposed to be
oh that's not from the game
it's fine don't worry about it
it's all good
that's from the game
hello oh i think that just circles back
to where i was
so that one
was supposed to make me feel better
because both are valid options
and good thing they have stairs going
down not like it was deep enough before
hi
hello that's blood um
hey
shut up
all right
okay that's dark um
i'm guessing this is dirt and not a pile
of entrails
usually what it turns out to be i'll go
to door
awfully windy in these catacombs well a
bad feeling about things has never
stopped me before so
did i knock did i just knock did i just
knock on that door and then it opened
lixie and did i just knock on that door
and then there's nothing here on the
other side that could have opened it
okay just checking
ah
this is all
really wonderful um
but at the o
iron maiden door different
do i have to choose i've been very bad
about my choices so far dead ahead
hello
hi
oh no
oh it's bodies okay well it is a
catacomb so this isn't exactly out of
the norm
well what was in the other door
oh blood oh
i got a good feeling about this ow
i thought this wasn't gonna go anywhere
because it was blood oh no
oh no
hi
hello
how are you how are you doing are you
looking at me i'm looking
okay
[Music]
all right
well
that guy didn't want to be disturbed
that's what i get for walking into
someone's bedroom
that's my bad other than that nothing
out of the ordinary i don't see any
great evil that i'm supposed to vanquish
and i don't know how i was supposed to
vanquish the evil in the first place
given that they didn't give me a weapon
to bank with it vanquish it with
oh god
it's a blood fountain
that's great
that's great
are there doors all around here oh no
well i don't like the way it rumbles
i'm just gonna go ahead and say that i
don't like the way that it rumbles
i don't like the rumbling
you really do knock you really do got a
knock on it oh up i don't know if i'm
supposed to go up
i don't know if up is what i want
let me just see my options here i got
the dark rumbling hallway i got the
stairs going up that is probably a false
hope and doesn't lead to the surface and
then i've got nothing else because there
wasn't a third option
i'm gonna go up up seems real good i
like up
up is the best
oh good bridge
this makes sense because we're
underground in a catacomb
oh good
down
i like that oh wait does this just
circle back
oh it does don't it it dude don't it
oh it did
it did but then what is here to the left
why does everything circle back it's
almost as if they designed this place
not to get lost in
why why why why why why you moving
why
why don't do that
okay
don't do that to me all right well i'm
hitting all the wrong ways
that's okay
i wanted this experience to last longer
i wanted to be down in the catacombs as
long as possible so that they send the
rescue team after me
is it too late to loudly proclaim that i
have a bad feeling about this
because i might maybe just have one of
those
oh
good
oh
found the butthole
great
i'm not gonna go there if i have a
choice between crawling in a hole that's
already at the bottom of a catacomb
i'm gonna choose not to do the uh
all right hole it is i always liked hole
hole's my only friend wait before i go
down this hole i think there might have
been another offshoot of the
the bridge you know the bridge the
perfectly logical and completely
ordinary bridge that exists underneath
underground
over a pitch black
chasm of nothingness
if this is another dead end i'm going to
be oh
well it's not a dead end except that
i'll be dead at the end of the hole
which is the bottom
all right
i'll go in the hole
rumbly
okay i'm in the butthole now
it's amazing and how many horror games i
find myself in some form of butt hole
most convenient means of transport if
you ask me
[Music]
okay
oh light at end of tunnel usually means
i'm dead or a way out
[Music]
or
oh my god why
would you do that what if i didn't look
behind me why do i continually have an
instinct to look behind me in these
games i don't know but that was very
good i like that [ __ ] terror very terror
very crypt i like it
moving on
[Music]
welcome to unhinged
n and his night vision i guess that
makes sense
the following footage was recovered from
banach banac
ban knack why is it towns out of cameron
banak montana after the events of 0606
2006
666. it has been compiled here in its
entirety for convenience the contents of
the following footage are next of an
extremely disturbing and possibly
graphic nature this may distress some
viewers this case is currently under
investigation
oh my god
whoa
don't need any of that
the field of view is nuts
wait was there dialogue at the bottom
lexi and put the dialogue in the bottom
at a texas piece so people can
understand what it was even if i don't
all right emily let's do our job inspect
everything in this area and head back to
the realtor's office something about an
investigation
i should stop working so late it got
dark
real dark real fast and maybe i can take
a day off next week
whoa grasshopper creek
all right
damn
tall house nice bike
you know they make electric
why
okay
all right
okay i'm going upstairs where i heard
the footsteps
oh blood well this
that don't really make sense for stairs
but okay
i could see doubly far with that
um
what
hello
okay
key
good what were you looking at
stars
or you some kind of a pervert
okay no
is that not it
i don't i don't use the key on the
the door
that make too much sense okay i guess
i'll
go somewhere else
was there a wolf in that house
where was there a wolf i didn't see no
hello
whoa
okay ah
shed
[Music]
ah you this is normal uh very normal is
that a foot
my god
look at the tootsies okay hi this is not
normal
hi what is that is that in test tunes
all right oh
all right
another key
okay and i have thank you
i'm guessing this is for the
the door inside
yeah well
i guess i got all of it nice chair for
the view i guess
an unmaintained propane tank
that's against regulations again don't
know why i'm coming in here solo for my
solo investigation but i feel like maybe
i should have some backup or a friend or
if i don't have any friends i could pay
someone to be here with me and if i
don't have any money i could kidnap them
and then eat their entrails and then i'd
be the person who is here can i go
downstairs
nope not that either
well i'm confused
okay
ah padlock
squeaky
what
oh no oh no no no just leave this place
it's not worth it just leave yeah you
right yeah you right you very right did
something throw my truck to something
did something throw my truck
well i'm knocking out that way i guess i
just run right
i'm just gonna run
there's the exit
i'm almost there
i'm gonna oh
oh no it's you
it's a werewolf
oh
where is this
lexi and pull up a map of where this is
i'm sure it's amazing all right pretty
good though moving on
welcome to they are here have you ever
wanted to be abducted by an alien
no well it's too late they're already
hovering over your house
don't look up
they'll find you anyway
anyway let's go get abducted unexplained
phenomena occurred at grey's wood farm
on the night of august 7th the sherman
family witnessed bright lights in the
sky that moved at breakneck speeds over
the cornfield the light moved in a
random direction and at different speeds
after a while they vanished this strange
behavior in the sky was observed at the
same time each night for five nights
according to the owner of the farm all
the animals went crazy the dogs became
aggressive tried to attack him and bit
him the children complained that someone
was walking under their windows farmer
peter sherman himself in the field saw a
strange figure that did not look like a
man what is it deliberate deception
drawing attention to oneself or a
sensation about an alien invasion
journalist taylor fox travels to
greywood farm to take a photo and make
report for the local newspaper
that i do i'm that reporter whatever
that name was that's me put it on my
name tag that's who i is stephanie
something
stephanie meyer the author of twilight
trying to get whoa
that's a problem goddamn drones
oh you do just give me the freedom to go
out here nah invisible wall i knew it
all right well i don't need anything
from my van and i'm assuming that i
don't need to come back to my van
also i'm assuming that i'm coming here
alone and that's fine oh
can i zoom
wham
nice
this is great material for a news report
says i this name i'm gonna make my big
break
i'm finally gonna
what am i seeing in the woods there
lixian am i crazy can you zoom in
enhance right by that tree right there
right where my reticle is right there
what is that zoom enhance
yeah maybe it's nothing hello
well this looks lovely
good corn
hey congrats on the corn
is the best corn i've ever seen
uh farmer you got your your corn's got
some problems hi
how are you
good to see you glad to be here okay
farmer's note
mr fox we made an appointment but
something bad happened our daughter went
missing my wife went to town for help my
son and i went to check out the farm
we'll leave notes for you and the police
in case we pass each other be careful
peter sherman
wait that's ps be careful
all right
well i'll be careful i suppose
let me just poke around your stuff you
don't mind me raiding your fridge do you
what a weird place for a fridge hi
in the photo members of the sherman
family
okay
and the alien in the bottom right corner
there
in the photo members of the sherman
family pointing at a mountain where
there is an alien
okay
i guess it would be impolite to steal
your food
hello goodbye
hello
well this is all delightful
hello
no one's home
i can just wander in this is fine
all good here
uh-huh
members of the sherman family i didn't
check the back of the other ones
downstairs but i don't think i need to
so i'll go back if i need to
wow
this is great
hello
hi don't mind me wandering into your
bedroom
nothing weird about that
well i could hide there
oh god hi
hello
photo from the internet perhaps peter
sherman saw something similar it looks
creepy yeah no joke what's with the
music
lixian what have i told you about
playing music in the background while
i'm doing things it makes me on edge
photo from the internet hmm
all right so all these are gonna be
photos from the internet unless there's
something on the back
which i doubt it
[Music]
okay well that's uh concerning
hmm found my old diary how could i
forget that today was the most exciting
and scariest day of my life i saw the
aliens my parents think i'm lying but
it's true i was fishing an abandoned
pond
of the river suddenly i was deafened by
a moan
coming from behind
i turned around
i
i went searching for the truth
and
like a fool i found it but
some truths
are best left undiscovered i turned
around and there was
bigger than i could imagine the hikers
claimed that when they turned around it
seemed as though their friend had simply
vanished when i turned around
my whole farm was gone i don't believe
in ghosts
but when i turned around
i couldn't explain what i was seeing
this is morbid mysteries of the missing
millennium
viewer discretion is advised
anyway i made that for distractible a
while ago i got to make more of those
they were super fun that took me like 30
minutes to do i got to do more of those
ah
someday okay i felt the punch that
seemed to throw me into the air i froze
there as if in zero gravity everything
around me became blindingly bright and i
seemed to lose consciousness i remember
seeing three aliens with gray skin and
big eyes i was placed on the table as if
i was welded to it they were standing
over me it seemed to me that they had
communicated with each other
telepathically
then one of them came over and did
something to my head i don't remember
anything else i woke up on the pier
later in the evening and barely made it
home my head was buzzing and i walked
home as if in a delirium when i got
there i found several cuts on my body
and two small very smooth holes behind
my ears
what was that i'm scared to sleep
oh god wham
this is great material for a news report
i've got great material for a news
report
sure hope something bad doesn't happen
to me
ah another note i learned a lot about
these things they're called the grays
these are not little green men but big
creepy and dangerous critters basically
they can be described in the following
way a large head disproportionate a body
no hair bottomless black eyes gray skin
long thin limbs their voices are like
nothing else these aliens are very
aggressive towards people it all starts
with bright lights in the sky near home
which move along a certain way then
people start to have a nosebleed have
severe headaches and a buzz in their
ears and animals start raging next
people start to have memory lapses when
they come back to normal they find
themselves in unexpected places for
example in the middle of a field or on a
road a few kilometers away from home
some of them have flashbacks to terrible
memories people remember terrifying
experiences the aliens established
control over their minds and this has
affected their psyche also they found
the marks on the body incisions to be
exact during palpation it felt like
something thick like a foreign object
moving under the skin
fine
lixie and be sure to put like stock
footage of aliens and creepy stuff while
i was reading that
for uh the viewers at home that might
get bored
i make it spooky hello that's weird i'm
gonna go ahead and say that's not normal
hmm
[Music]
it looks like this drawing was made by
the missing daughter of the farmer the
paper's painted on both oh
no
ah
just gotta put that back put it back
put it back
all right
this is my daughter's room during the
night i heard a strange noise when i
came in she wasn't in her bed and the
window was wide open i'm sure she was
abducted by those things
put it back anything on the back put it
back
why
oh
no
[Music]
good thing i have one of these
all right megan
hello why are you running into the woods
why would you do that
apparently it belonged to the missing
girl if you listen closely you hear very
strange sounds i thought something was
to my left and i
something might be to my left
hello
great
oh this is good hi
is anybody in the house
mister
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god
okay well that's not good um
holy [ __ ]
who's there
don't make me hide in the closet i will
do that um if someone is downstairs say
a big alien or something like that with
big eyes can you keep your eyes really
wide open i just want to point out
something to you
really don't blink don't
blink oh god no
if they read okay the fridge is safe
we're all okay
as a child headaches begin to bother me
they torture me to this day i went to
the doctors dozens of times but no one
could explain the reason for their
occurrence now i understand why the
doctors could not determine the cause of
the migraines the answer is simple
abduction i only remembered the alien
abduction when i found my whole diary it
was then that the migraines began the
cuts that i noticed then behind the ear
were a trace of them i'm sure they've
implanted something in me some kind of
transmitter implant because of this i
forgot everything i definitely decided
that i would get it i'm not crazy
oh did you try to carve oh you did
oh wow that is actually something maybe
take it probably not the best idea
because if it's a tracker then they're
going to be able to find me but
um ah screw it
it'll be great in my report i'm
definitely not gonna get abducted
but getting abducted would be good for
the news story i'm sure there's nothing
behind me oh i hate this
i'm not gonna look anywhere around me
ever
ever at all
guys
everyone watching this at home i can't
look at you right now but stay glued to
the screen do not look around you don't
even try it don't even risk it don't
look to your side don't try to sneak a
look over your shoulder definitely don't
look behind you
just keep your eyes locked on the screen
right now i cannot look back at you
right now because i have to keep my eyes
glued
to exactly what's in front of me
i'm gonna look behind me we're all gonna
look behind us in three
two one
all right how many are still alive out
there how am i still alive raise your
hand if you're still alive
okay good i mean acceptable casualties
that's good that's good that's good what
do we have here oh that's
a dead animal
[Music]
oh
well that's uncomfortable
so what did i uh glean from that what
did uh what what what did i glean
[Music]
911
nine one one please all right i'm coming
for you
keep those peepers peeled
heal your
peel your peepers
okay well uh time to go home oh not that
home
oh look i'm focusing
uh oh
oh
no
well uh
all's well it ends well
i'll just be on my way good day to you
i hate
them
i'm not looking at you
i would never i would i'm running i'm
running i'm running i'm what weird i'm
going now
in my van i'm getting in
good thing i don't have any kind of
alien tracking device
an alien air tag is not on my person
[Music]
well
oh
goodness oh
why
oh
i missed it do it again
oh
no
oh
did you punch me
did you punch me
all of your alien technology you can't
even invent clothes and also you punched
me
that was pretty cool though that was
actually really well made for a demo
like it is one of those things that had
some potential to it i did like that
there are so many of these games that i
play in the demo stage and they never
continue on so be sure to support these
games so that we can play more of them
more horror games is better for
[Music]
you will now everybody to your home
don't worry
we will be monitoring you
forever
[Music]
you